MILITARY FOCUSES SOLELY ON
FIGHTING REAL WORLD ARE SCUM,
BUT NOT CULTURE WARS.
ACUTE WHILE THE OBAMA
MINISTRATION REFUSES TO TAKE ON
CHINA.
PARENTS ARE STANDING UP TO THE
THREAT OF CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
MY NEXT GUEST WENT VIRAL AND HA
A BRILLIANT TAKEDOWN AT THE
IDEOLOGY AT SCHOOL BOARD MEETIN
FOR IT.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY WHICH IS PRETTY MUCH
TEACHING YOUR KIDS HOW TO HATE
EACH OTHER, HOW TO DISLIKE EACH
OTHER.
THAT IS PRETTY MUCH WHAT IT IS
COMES DOWN TO.
WORK MY WAY THROUGH COLLEGE,
WORK MY OFF TO GET THROUGH
COLLEGE, YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT
SOMEBODY WHO DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
YOU WHITE FOLKS CAN'T DO IT.
>> THE ILLINOIS DAD AND RADIO
HOST, TIE COMING OUT DURING THA
MEETING, YOU NOT ONLY CALLED OU
THE CRITICAL RACE THEORY FOLKS,
BUT ALSO CALLED OUT THE PEOPLE
PUSHING IT FOR IT IGNORING
THINGS THAT ARE ACTUALLY VERY
POSITIVE FOR BLACK COMMUNITIES,
EXPLAINED THAT.
>> THE THING IS THAT MOST OF TH
TIME YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN A ROOM
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYBODY JUST
JUMPS ON BOARD WITH WHAT'S GOIN
ON, THEY GIVE NO THOUGHT TO IT
THEY ASKED NO QUESTIONS.
IF THIS PERSON'S SAID IT'S RIGHT
, SO IT MUST BE RIGHT SO
LET'S EVERYBODY JUMP ON BOARD.
LIES AT THE ROOM I LOOKED AROUN
AND THOUGHT I'M THE ONLY BLACK
PERSON IN THERE AND I HAVE ALL
THESE WHITE PEOPLE TALKING ABOU
THE BLACK EXPERIENCE AND I
THOUGHT HOW DID THEY KNOW THIS
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER SEEN ANY OF
THESE FOLKS IN THE AREAS I GREW
UP AND IN LIVED, YET TO BE ON
THE OUTSIDE LIKE THEY WERE,
DOING ALL THIS VIRTUAL SIGNALING
, I WAS JUST SO WORKED
UP BECAUSE I WAS CALLING BS
BECAUSE THE VERY THING THEY WER
TALKING ABOUT I WAS THAT KID IN
THE GHETTO.
I WAS THAT KID IN THE HOOD.
I'M LIKE NO, WHAT YOU'RE TALKIN
ABOUT, YOU GUYS WEREN'T THE
PROBLEM BEAR THE ISSUE THAT A
LOT OF BLACK PEOPLE HAVE RIGHT
NOW IS THAT IS TO REALIZE THAT
WE ARE THE BIGGEST PROBLEM IN
THE BIGGEST THREAT TO US
PROGRESSING.
NOT WHITE PEOPLE.
>> WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
THIS IN THE PREVIOUS SEGMENT
WHICH IS OF COURSE, THE CRIME I
THE INNER-CITY.
NOW THAT WE HAVE A DEFUND POLIC
MOVEMENTS, WE HAVE DEMONIZATION
OF POLICE, POLICE ARE BAD, NOT
DIVERSE, WHATEVER THE CONCERN I
AND THAT IS LEADING TO THE DEAT
OF MORE MINORITIES.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THAT, THAT'S NOT A
CONVENIENT NARRATIVE.
IT RATHER TALK ABOUT HOW
EVERYONE IS SO RACIST IN THE
SCHOOLS AND TURN THE KIDS
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
>> THEY'VE GOT YOU FOCUSED ON
SOMETHING ELSE BY PUTTING YOUR
BEHIND YOUR BACK IS GOING ON.
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENING, I
DON'T CARE IF ANYBODY WANTS TO
AGREE WITH ME OR NOT, THE
BIGGEST WAY TO ME GROWING UP WA
SOMEBODY THAT LOOKED EXACTLY
LIKE ME.
I HAD NO THREAT FROM ANY WHITE
POLICE OFFICER OR ANY WHITE
PERSON WHATSOEVER.
THERE WAS NO SYSTEM THERE THAT
THEY CLAIM WAS THERE, I'M SORRY
BACK IN THE DAY, SLAVE DAYS AND
THREE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT, I
DON'T GET THAT, BUT IN TODAY'S
WORLD, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
ALL THE DOING IS HANDING FOLKS
WHOPPERS.
>> WHY ARE THEY DOING IT?
WHY ARE THEY PUSHING THIS ON TH
KIDS?
COULD GET THEY WANT THEM TO
BELIEVE THEY CAN'T ACHIEVE
ANYTHING GOOD OR THEY WANT TO B
ABOUT THEIR RACE.
AND I TOLD THEM, THE VERY PERSO
THAT CLAIMS THAT THEY ARE
HELPING YOU IS YOU KEEP HANDING
A PERSON IN SAYING THIS IS ME
HELPING YOU, THAT PERSON WILL
NEVER BECOME INDEPENDENT.
WHEN MY DEGREES AS PHYSICAL
THERAPY.
THE NUMBER ONE GOAL IS TO GET
OUR PATIENTS INDEPENDENT AS THE
BECOME STRONGER AND MORE
PROGRESSING IN THEIR THE SET
PROGRAMS FOR THEM, WE TAKE THAT
THIS BECAUSE THEY'RE BECOMING
MORE INDEPENDENT WHICH MEANS
THEY CAN DO THINGS ON THEIR OWN
WHAT WE GET FROM THE GOVERNMENT
IS A BIT THIS IS ME HELPING YOU.
THIS IS US HELPING YOU, BUT
HAVING NO IDEA IT'S DAMAGING
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO REMAIN
DISABLED.
>> AND DEPENDENT ON THE
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S THAT
THRESHOLD, THE CEILING, CAN'T G
ANY FURTHER IF YOUR DEPENDENT O
THE GOVERNMENT.